on circle Oh below so this is circle Oh
segment s II is a diameter so this is s
II I can actually let me color that in
so this is the diameter that's what
they're telling us
that's SE and they say what is the
measure of angle I s II
so what we care about the measure of
angle is e I se4 trying to figure out
this angle right over there and like
always I encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can work through it
yourself so there's a bunch of ways that
we can actually tackle this problem the
first one that jumps out at me is
there's a bunch of triangles here and we
can use the fact that the that the
angles the interior angles of a triangle
add up to 180 degrees so we could look
at this triangle right over here and so
we know one of the angles already we
know this angle is 20 has a measure of
27 degrees if we could figure out this
angle right over here this is what would
be angle s ie then if we know two angles
two interior angles of a triangle we can
figure out the third and this one s ie
we can figure it out because it's
supplementary to this 61 degree angle so
this angle right over here is just going
to be this angle plus the 61 degree
angle is going to be equal to 180
degrees because they are supplementary
or we could say that this angle right
over here is going to be 180 minus 61 so
what is that going to be 180 minus 60 to
be 120 and then minus one and BS is is
119 119 degrees and so this angle that
we trying to figure out this angle plus
the 119 degrees plus the 27 degrees is
going to be equal to 180 degrees or we
could say that this angle is going to be
180 minus 119 minus 27 which is going to
be equal to so let's see 180 minus 119
is 61 and then 61 minus 27 is going to
be 34 so there you have it
measure of angle is e is 34 degrees now
I mentioned that there is multiple ways
that we could figure this out let me let
me do it one more way so let me unwind
everything that I just wrote we already
figured out the answer but I want to
show you that there's multiple ways that
we can tackle this so IC is still the
thing that we want to figure out another
way that we could approach it is well we
know we have some angles inscribed
angles on this circle and we know that
if an inscribed angle intercepts the
diameter then it's going to be a right
angle it's going to be a 90-degree angle
so this angle right over here is a 90
degree angle and we can use that
information to figure out this angle and
we could also use that information if we
look at a different so if we look at
this triangle we could use 90 plus 61
Plus this angle is going to be equal to
180 degrees so this angle right over
here another way to think about it it's
going to be 180 minus 90 minus 61 which
is equal to 180 minus 90 is 90 minus 61
is 29 degrees so this one right over
here is 29 degrees 29 degrees and then
we could look at this larger triangle we
could look at this larger triangle right
over here to figure out this entire
angle to figure out this entire angle if
we know this entire angle you subtract
29 then you figure out angle is e and so
this large ortho what I've depicted is
this kind of this magenta this measure
right over here of that angle plus 90
degrees plus 27 degrees is going to be
equal to 180 because they're the
interior angles of triangle SL e so this
angle right over here is going to be 180
minus 61 minus 27 sorry not minus 61
minus 90 minus 90 it's it's 180 minus 90
minus 27 is going to give us this angle
right over here because the three angles
add up to 180 so minus 90 minus 27
which is equal to so 180 minus 90 is 90
90 minus 27 90 minus 27 is 63 63 degrees
so this large one over here is 63
degrees and the smaller one is 29
degrees and so angle is e which we set
out to figure out is going to be 63
degrees minus the 29 degrees so 63 minus
29 is once again equal to 34 degrees so
the way I did it just now a little bit
harder it really depends what jumps out
at you the way the first way I tackled
it it does seem a little bit easier a
little bit clearer but it's good to see
these different things and at least you
know here we use this idea of an
inscribed angle that intercepts a
diameter and if you say hey how do we
know I mean we prove it in other videos
but it comes straight out of the idea
that the inscribed angle the measure of
an inscribed angle is going to be half
of the of the measure of the arc that it
intercepts and notice it's intercepting
an arc that has a measure of 180 degrees
its intercepting an arc that has a
measure of 180 degrees and so this angle
is going to be half of that since it's
an inscribed angle not a central angle
and so it's going to be a 90-degree
angle